parece una película de terror pero es
real son las imágenes de la cámara de
uno de los policías tras entrar en una
escuela primaria de Nashville en pleno
tiroteo escucharon tiros en la segunda
planta donde encontraron al autor del
crimen y lo mataron
momentos antes el atacante Audrey hombre
transgénero baleó una de las puertas
secundarias y entró al colegio infantil
para perpetrar el crimen cargaba dos
rifles de asalto y una pistola que
compró legalmente en la zona y con los
que mató a varios adultos y niños y
aunque aún no sean esclarecido los
motivos del ataque si se sabe que hale
fue estudiante del centro y que el
suceso no fue casual tenía mapas
detallados y un manifiesto al respecto
tras los hechos los niños y los
trabajadores del recinto fueron
escoltados con un cordón de seguridad
hasta una iglesia los vecinos de la zona
que hicieron una ceremonia para honrar a
la memoria de las víctimas estar
conmocionados y con la de tiroteos en
escuelas que está viviendo el país desde
2022 muchos están también indignados soy
de Highland Park Illinois mi hijo y yo
sobrevivimos a un tiroteo masivo en
julio Cómo puede seguir ocurriendo esto
Cómo siguen muriendo nuestros hijos
porque les estamos fallando la violencia
Armada es la principal causa de muerte
de niños y adolescentes solo en lo que
llevamos de año Este es el décimo tercer
tiroteo en escuelas de Estados Unidos
que termina con heridos y víctimas
mortales